let's bring in the Hall of Famer NFL
Network analyst Kurt Warner who joins us
now a little bit of a shocker there on
Saturday what was your first reaction
Kurt I mean I think it was like everyone
else's I mean I I don't think anybody
saw this coming you know especially at
this age at this time we all assumed
that no matter what happened this year
that he would continue to kind of work
through it so I think we're all
surprised but at the same time when you
hear him having been through different
situations in the league I completely
understand it do you think there's
something else that we're missing here I
don't I really think that the bottom
line with the game is that so many
people get into the game because they
they love the game and then there always
seems to be a time when the other stuff
starts to outweigh the love for the game
you know that the Sunday afternoons
nobody stops loving but it's the
preparation it's the offseason and with
Andrew Luck you know it intensifies with
all the rehab and all the pain and
you're never healthy to be able to just
show up and enjoy what you're doing and
I just think it's it's you know going on
for so long that just like he said I
used to love the game now everything
else seems to outweigh my love for the
game in it and it makes it hard to get
up every week going okay here's my week
I got to go do rehab for two hours and
go through all day and then I got to do
rehab again and you know hopefully by
Sunday I'll be able to play pain-free
and do what I love to do but it's always
in the back of mind or you're always
playing hurt and then you have the
expectations I think of now it's when's
he gonna be back out there he needs to
be back out there this team needs and it
seems a championship type team and the
pressure of going I'm still not healthy
what the heck do I do now you know do I
go and play anyways even though I know
I'm not a hundred percent or do I let
this thing kind of play out and then I
hear everybody saying well he should be
out there why is he not out there I see
him doing drills and doing this he looks
like he's good enough to be out there I
just think it weighs on your mind you
know for so long and it's been going on
you know for a number of years now that
I think he's just kind of like I'm tired
of dealing with all the other stuffs
more than I'm dealing with actually
playing and doing what I love doing what
I don't understand I don't know if you
can help me understand this but you he
just it feels like he made an abrupt
decision here now I know he's a thought
out guide deep thinker you know two
weeks ago he talked about he he got
depressed going through all this rehab
that was the first that was the light
that went on for me when I went oh wow
okay I didn't expect to hear that from
him and then when he said that I thought
all right but he's healthy now or
healthier now good offensive line Super
Bowl contender so something it feels
like happen for you to make a decision
that feels like you made a snap judgment
here yeah I mean I understand exactly
what you're saying because I think a lot
of times we have those feelings as you
said it comes to a point where like I
I'm just gonna retire and then you got
to take some time and really think about
it and think about the long term and
it's just really what I want four or
five years from now and not be playing
this game that I love but I have to
believe that you know even though he
said he really kind of sat down and
thought about it I had to believe this
was weighing on his mind for a long
period of time and I think maybe you
know you get two weeks to the season and
everybody's expecting you to play and I
wonder if that plays into it a little
bit as well like I don't think I'm gonna
be out there for week one and you know I
don't want to have to tell everybody you
know I know how long it's going to go on
and we're going week to week that you
just kind of go I'm just going to retire
and let the team move on and move
forward and I'll kind of get some
closure on this and being able to step
away from it but I think it does lend
itself you guys we're talking about your
you know your poll question I think it
does lend itself to okay if you made a
snap decision and it's because you're
not feeling good right now you're only
29 years old does it really open up the
door for 12 months from now when you
actually feel really good and know you
can still play this game to try to come
back and play and and what does that
mean if you go about it this way
talking to hall-of-famer Kurt Warner you
can see him every Sunday on NFL
Network's NFL gameday morning at 9:00
a.m. Eastern starting September 8 I'm
curious in you being in Arizona this
whole clapping with
Kyler's Marie and and the Cardinals what
what am I missing here that they're
doing something illegal I don't think
you're missing anything you know I
actually got a video from their their
media director just yesterday and it was
comparing things that other quarterbacks
have been doing the last couple years
with clapping and kind of the gyrations
back here on the shotgun to what kind of
memory did in the preseason game that
got called for and his is is way less
than what some of these other guys were
doing Sam Donal to josh allen and so i
was with you i went back and watched the
tape over and over again going okay what
am I missing here and then they actually
got called and it was actually Brett
Hundley but he got a call from Blake
I made this past weekend I mean he just
lifted his leg nothing I don't know what
we're missing if they're just trying to
make a point like hey this is new this
is different you know we're going to be
very cautious with this and not let you
do anything but from what I've seen up
to at this point it seems like they're
being targeted a little bit because
they're kind of in the forefront with
this but I don't see anything that you
know I can't believe they're going to
continue to call in the regular season
what they've been calling in the
preseason what if what have you seen
from Kyle Emery I like Tyler you know
but out to practice you know watched all
the games you know the biggest thing for
me is I think he needs to get better or
this offense needs to be better at
handling the Blitz there seems to be a
number of times it gets Minnesota and
against Oakland where they were bringing
pressure and he either didn't have an
answer or he wasn't ready with the
answer against the pressure and they've
got it they better figure that out or
that's gonna be a problem but I think
you saw yesterday there was three or
four just big-time throws from Kyle
Avery I think he's in control he
understands that the moments not too big
I really like him I'm not sure they have
the pieces around him right now for him
to be everything he's going to be but
he's not my biggest concern by any means
with with the Cardinals this year well
that leads me to this question about
putting him in there with an inferior
line that they didn't improve upon last
year and now I'm gonna put him out there
the last thing I want is my rookie
quarterback
go out there and lose confidence be
gun-shy and always be looking you know
that ghosts out there they should he be
starting week one given that offensive
line yes he should be because they're
moving forward to the future and Brett
Hundley is not any part of that and so
yeah I think he should be starting and I
understand your point and I think a big
part of that is always knowing who your
quarterback is what kind of confidence
he has if he goes through some struggles
do you think that's gonna affect him
long-term and you know I think you have
to know that first and foremost and
everything I've heard and everything in
my conversations with Tyler I don't
worry about that I don't look at a guy
that's going to get done shy at any
point time he's a guy that believes he
can make every play he believes he's the
best player on the field Andrew Luck was
another guy he got you know beat up a
lot obviously it's paying some bad
dividends now for the team but he got
beat up a lot when he was young and he
never got gunshot he never shrunk from
that and I don't think Kyle Emery is
that kind of guy but I think it's
important that the organization know who
that quarterback is when they put him in
and that's why I fully believe he should
be the starter week one regardless of
what they have around him and you might
take your lumps early but it's going to
pay dividends for him and for this team
in a long run what would you do with
Daniel Jones with the Giants well I mean
I think you again I said there's a
number of times I think Eli's earned the
right to play himself out of the
position and so I know Daniel has played
well in the preseason but this is Eli's
job and it deserves to be his job until
he shows that he's not the better
quarterback come regular season and when
you're seeing real defenses and when
that point time comes I think it will be
tough to figure out the right timing and
how to do it but I think eli holds the
job this entire year until the
organization is fully believes that
Daniel Jones is the better quarterback
and I'm still not sure that's the case
right now who's your sneaky team this
year there's always one or two that move
up and one or two that moved down
that's a good question you know I mean
and again it's what are you what do you
base it off of I mean you know the two
teams that I think are gonna make big
jumps this year are Atlanta in Minnesota
and again I don't know if you look at
them and go oh they're sneaky because I
mean you know Minnesota's got everything
you know they've got to be a playoff
team this year in Atlanta I mean they
went through so many injuries last year
but their offense
you should be dynamic and as long as
they're decent on defense they should
make a move and you know be in the
playoffs this year as well and so those
are kind of mighty that are on the
outside that I'm looking at and going
they've got to make a run and be much
better than they were record wise last
year is it time for Tennessee to move on
for Marcus Mariota I think it's time to
be on a short leash as much as I like
Marcus as a guy they're just not the
consistency there and now you've got a
guy that has started in this league
behind him that I think you have to see
more consistency week in and week out or
you do have to make the move because you
know I mean this is a year it's either
you're signing into the long franchise
deal or you're not and you know if
you're already convinced he's your guy
than I am and I don't know why you
brought in Ryan Tannehill but you have
to believe they don't believe that right
now and if he doesn't come out and show
that consistency I think you got to
figure out if the other guy is that guy
and and move forward Kurt great to talk
to you we appreciate it and look forward
to those Sunday mornings all right buddy
that's Kurt Warner NFL Network the
Sunday morning show with Rich Eisen NFL
gameday morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern
starting September 8 for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]